First, I would like to thank the trustees,
the faculty and the students for this honor.
And and to my family.
Because. Because.
Without you, I.
Uh. I'm sorry.
I'd like to apologize.
Because I've led you all to believe that I'm
worthy of this award.
And. I'm not.
Because.
Because I'm a drug addict.
Really f***ing good one too.
I I'm high on coke most days.
In fact, I'm high right now and.
I know how to say and do what I need to get
everyone to believe what I want them to.
I look at the people who
love and support me every day and I lie to
them. And I feel like sh*t.
And I don't want to anymore.
I'm definitely nobody's hero.
I'm sorry.
I don't even know where to
start. Cocaine.
This is serious.
How long? How long have you been doing this
sh*t?
Phil? No.
Just let me talk to my son, please.
How long?
Two. Maybe three.
Years. Where do you keep it?
I uh.
In this
house?
Look, I just I.
Where do you get it?
Look, it's not that hard to find.
Who do you do it with?
Everyone. Dad, it's Bel Air.
How do you pay for it?
Because he sure as hell don't have a job.
I mean, I have money.
Right?
You get a weekly allowance for doing, not a
god damn thing.
Don't. Don't look at her.
She's not going to bail you out. Not. Not
this time. Okay? Okay.
Maybe we just need to take a breath just now.
It's just now is not the time.
And when is the time, Viv?
When we find him strung out in his room.
In the streets or, oh, when we bury him
because he didn't have the backbone to say
no to what everyone else was doing at Bel
Air.
I'm sorry, dad.
All right.
Whatever you needed, we made sure you have
it. The best schools, tutors, therapists,
assessments, doctors.
I've given you the best of everything I've
got.
And you wish that you had a stronger son.
Right. A son that didn't need meds or have
anxiety or panic attacks.
Look, trust me, dad, I know I'm not the son
you dreamed of.
If I grew up with half the things you have.
The opportunities.
I didn't have any of this sh*t.
Right?
You came from nothing.
And you never let me forget how lucky I am.
How many times do I have to apologize for
giving everybody else a great f***ing life?
Well, I'm done taking the blame.
Give him time.
We're going to get you better.